[Applaudissements]
et après ça c'est je
chante je
chante je chante soir et matin je chante
sur mon chemin je chante je vais de
faire mon château je chante pour du pain
je chante pour de l'eau je couche la
nuit sur l'herbe les voir les mouche ne
me pque pas je suis heureux j'ai tout et
j'ai rien je chante sur mon chemin les
elfes divinité de la nuit les elfes
couffent dans mon lit la lune se
fauxfile à bas de nous dans le bois pour
danser pour danser avec nous je sonne
chez la comtesse aujourd'hui personne
elle est partie elle n'a laissé qu'un
plat ride pour moi me dit un laqu
chinois je chante mais la faim qui me
pours je suis tourmente mon appétit je
tombe soudain au creux dans sentier je
défaille en tombant et je meurs à moitié
et gendarmes qui passaient sur le chemin
gendarme je tends les mains pitié j'ai
faim je voudrais manger je suis tout
léger léger au poste d'utre moustache m
dit au poste ah mon ami oui oui oui oui
c'est vous le le chanteage le vagab on
va vous enfermer oui votre côte est bon
non
ficelle tu m'as sauvé de la vie ficelle
sois donc béni car grâce à toi j'ai ru
l'esprit je me suis fondu cette nuit et
deit je chante je chante soir et matin
je chante sur les chemins je hante les
fermes et les châteaux un fon qui chante
contau et je
cou la nuit sur l'herbe des vois les
mouches ne me F pas non non non non je
suis heureux ça va j'ai plus FA et
chante sur mon
[Musique]
chemin